[Music]
[Applause]
spontaneous copying going on right here
in the newsroom that's all fans of
Rivera doing the Carleton it's a dance
move that debuted in the TV comedy The
Fresh Prince of bel-air and then
recently showed up on in the video game
fortnight that prompted a lawsuit from
Ribeiro and he later dropped but in fact
his case is not quite unique some of the
most recognizable dance routines of
recent years are now generating big
profits for some companies without
compensation for the people who created
them christina Ruffini has a story when
Radford to Millie's dance the Milly Rock
went viral he said he never thought
about copyrighting when you saw like
kids or other people just copying moves
and kind of posting the video did that
bother you that was like love I'll
repost it on my page what he didn't love
is when fans started messaging him to
say a popular online video game was
making money off his moves some other
people would just go blatantly you have
to sue for at night and I'm like what is
for tonight adventure awaits for tonight
is a free online game with a hundred and
twenty five million players its creator
epic makes money through in-game add-ons
including short dances players can pay
to use this one is called swiping that's
my moves right there
but epic says it's avatars can dance if
they want to because Milius moves and
those of the five other artists trying
to sue the company are too simple -
trademark attorney David Hackett
represents the plaintiffs what are the
parameters for copywriting the
choreography and you look at things like
plagiarism you know there's a certain
number of words but dance doesn't quite
work like that
none of those boundaries have ever been
defined by the courts so there's this
inherent lack of any kind of a fixed
line or any kind of a definitive answer
to your question choreographers have
danced around this issue for more than a
century in 1892 Louis filler was denied
a trademark for her famous serpentine
routine because back then the law only
protects
did works that told a story then came
the modern dance movement in the 1970s
copyright expanded to cover abstract and
non narrative movement but like a lot of
today's viral artists many dancers never
bothered to register their works in the
early days it wasn't about that it was
about experimenting it was about getting
your work out there LaRue Allen is the
director of the Martha Graham Dance
Company when its founder died in the
early 90s the company found itself at
the center of a landmark lawsuit with
the heir to her estate we were told by
the air that we couldn't perform her
work or teach or technique did that shut
you down it did for a brief period of
time yes it did each of Graham's 181
works had to be litigated individually
eventually the company regained the
right to perform almost all of the
dances but the Graham technique the
stylized steps and movements she created
were not copyrighted Graham technique as
such is taught in many different venues
around the world absolutely like ballet
and that is okay now the courts will
have to decide if they're really rock
and other viral dances are considered
basic steps like a styler technique or
protective intellectual property win or
lose - Millie says he hopes the
publicity will help other artists learn
from his mistake people would be more
aware like oh we just created that and
went viral today well we're going to
copyright this tomorrow
nobody's gonna be able to still see
where she would have done that yeah yeah
[Laughter]
this is a teachable moment yes I really
do well it's you know I really do
believe they should be able to cover it
I don't know where you draw the line I
don't where you draw the line but but I
totally get it it's an artistic creation
why shouldn't you have ownership somehow
you do over your own moves but you know
an elbow shake or a sliding of the feet
I mean
that's like a musical note you can't
copyright that but there's a certain way
yeah but and he will always have him yes
that's true what we'll always have that
but you look at that fan dancer that I
could ever do it yeah I could copy the
my moves but I wouldn't have the the
well there's that there's that there's
that too